attention aux apparences dans le
reportage que nous allons vous présenter
maintenant il y aura du sable du soleil
et de l'eau et cela peut évoquer bien
sur la côte atlantique où la côte de la
méditerranée mais c'est à saint quentin
dans l'aisne loin de la mer que ces
images ont été tournées sophie rolland
la plage à domicile place de l'hôtel de
ville 800 tonnes de table des paliers
une piscine de 200 m² début juillet
l'été commençait plutôt bien pour les
saint quentinois le succès de l'an
dernier avait poussé la mairie à
renouveler l'opération avec quelques
améliorations à cette année on évolue
déjà dans un cadre beaucoup plus
exotique est beaucoup plus d'évasion
mais il ya aussi plus de loisirs plus de
sport ou voyez derrière vit une vraie
piscine qui vous qui permet justement à
tous les enfants voulaient tous les
quartiers d'avoir des loisirs totalement
gratuit
mais il ya une semaine tempête sur le
sable la piscine est vidée raison
invoquée les contrôles sanitaires ont
découvert des bactéries dans l'eau
étonnement à la mairie selon elle toutes
les précautions nécessaires avaient été
prises
nous pensions s'il suffisait de
renouveler complètement le bassin de le
nettoyer de fond en compte de changer
les filtres des pontes ce qui a été fait
après 4 nettoyage successifs la piscine
a pu rouvrir hier mais il ne reste que
cinq jours pour profiter de loi 18
degrés l'opération se termine dimanche
pas facile d'improviser une plage quand
on a eu des phases